I have often felt like a fish out water
at various points throughout my career
I've definitely come to the realization
that my diversity and the difference
that I bring is a real strength my first
tip is dare to be different
it can weigh heavily on your shoulders
and it can be quite frightening I think
to to take a risk and do something
different and to break new ground
sometimes people will question you and
question whether you're making the right
decision and sometimes you'll question
yourself and but that's okay
[Music]
my family come from East Africa and
India and so they are the children of
Britain's colonial past when I said to
some members of my extended family that
I was going to work for the Foreign
Office there was an immediate sense of
you know how could you how could you do
this do you not remember what they did
to our people but I think you need to
recognize that and if you break new
ground there will be people who question
me but if you believe that it's the
right thing to do you need you need to
persevere
so my next tip is accept fear so I know
that when I'm in new uncomfortable
situations and I get a strong sense of
fear and my flight mechanism kicks in
and for me that starts with butterflies
in my tummy and it goes on to trying to
think through how can I get out of this
situation
so when I joined GCHQ I definitely felt
in those early days that sense of fear
and flight and I'm surrounded by some
incredibly intelligent people and
they're gonna find me out pretty quickly
I've learned over the years that
actually that feeling only stays with me
for a relatively short period of time
and if I ride it out and if I accept
fear that actually it will be fine and
the rational side
ask questions that's my next top tip
because it's only through asking and
really listening to what people say that
you can build relationships of trust and
confidence and in my job I often meet
people from international backgrounds
and the one thing that I always do is to
look at what's on the front page of
their local newspaper that day and
because that gives me something topical
to talk to them about what you're trying
to do is to make the people feel that
you're really interested in them and
what they have to say to you my final
tip is find the champion I think it's
really really important when you're
breaking new ground to find somebody who
will encourage you to be yourself and
will advocate for you for me I was lucky
that I was able to find a champion
fairly early on in my career and she is
somebody that I will turn to and ask for
advice and guidance but also don't
forget that you are a champion yourself
I learned something which was lift as
you climb so making sure that you're
helping somebody else to succeed part of
what drives me is proving people wrong
the people who said that I couldn't
possibly work for for the Foreign Office
because it wasn't for people from from
my background so success for me isn't
about the glory of being at the top of
an organization it's about having the
maximum impact that I can but also about
being an inspiration so if I can change
the conversations and encourage people
to dare to be different and to take a
risk then I feel like I will have
succeeded
you